let me also remind you if you ever use
amazon.com to buy stuff on the internet
the shopping you do can support the work
we do all you have to do is go to david
pakman.com slash amazon before shopping
and then anything you buy will send us a
little kickback Louis Rogaine men men's
hair regrowth foam was purchased over
the weekend I recently had a
conversation with a couple of people I
know who are starting to lose their hair
and some of them are very scared of
using some of these treatments because
of the side effects as you know my
little brother started losing his hair
pretty early on had a consultation with
the dermatologist who provided some of
these options and he decided the side
effects were not worth it for him what
are a few of them uh well I don't know
if we want to get into that but I think
impotence is one or well yeah um so
anyway I don't know I I am more worried
about losing my hair than it going gray
because if you really don't like gray
hair there's a pretty simple fix to that
the the baldness solutions seem to be a
little more complex and invasive if you
want to go with like a transplant or
whatever else yeah those do seem to work
but certainly not up a pleasant
experience and there's going to be a
period of time where your head might
look pretty ridiculous uh because of how
that works but I some people do say that
this stuff works absolutely if you've
had success with these I would be
interested in hearing from our audience
people who have used them and we have a
lot of friends Louis we're starting to
see those hairlines receding and they're
starting to think about what will their
plan be going forward also a lot of
people purchasing through our amazon
link rich hill which was my documentary
from last week as well as walkable city
which was the book by a guest we
interviewed last week so thanks to
everybody who continues to use that link
david pakman.com slash amazon warby
parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into
two stores and trying on glasses while
the salesperson sort of hovers over me
and I like more than 30 seconds to
actually figure out whether I like the
glasses so with the Warby Parker home
try-on I was able to pick five pairs
that i liked put them on in the comfort
of my own home pick the one I like the
most and then Warby Parker put my
prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing